well we begin with breaking news from
Iraq where the prime minister-designate
has resigned the second to do so since
anti-government protests began back in
October Adnan al-safi had until April
15th to form a new government but there
was mounting opposition from some
parties to his candidacy well let's go
straight now to simona fulton who's live
for us in baghdad simona talked us
through what's prompted all of this well
at Nana's or if it became the second
person to withdraw his candidacy for the
prime minister post in just six weeks
and of course this comes amid a
month-long leadership crisis in Iraq do
we have seen unfold since December
really when caretaker Prime Minister
Abdullah Marti was forced to resign amid
widespread government protests since
then we have observed that the political
establishment has struggled to come up
with a candidate that is acceptable to
all of the political factions and that
also has support from the protesters who
have been asking for systematic change
now at Nana's office specifically he
faced a lot of opposition from some of
the Iranian backed groups who saw him as
being very close to the United States
they then came up with their own
proposal for a prime minister a man
called Mustafa Academy he is currently
the chief of the Intelligence Service
what is ironic that he too is seen as
somebody who is rather close to the
United States but he has now been put
forth as an alternative to zuri he has
apparently secured the support of
several political parties from across
the spectrum including Shia Sunni and
Kurds and he is at the moment at the
presidential palace being nominated as
the next prime minister-designate to be
tasked with forming a new government and
simona after all of these months of
demonstrations that we saw where does
all of this now leave the protest
movement itself
well the protest movement is one could
say almost extinct and this is in part
because there is currently a curfew in
place due to the corona virus pandemic
there are only a few dozen protesters in
Tahrir
which has been the epicenter of the
protests but of course if you look back
over the past few months that protest
movement has been gradually weakened due
to various reasons and if you go back to
the demands that the protesters put
forth they really wanted a complete
overhaul of the political system they
wanted a head of state who was not
beholden to any political interests
somebody who was who was a new figure a
new face who could really bring about
far-reaching change and that has not
really been the case with any of the
nominees that have been put forward you
have most about most of our card I mean
are the latest prime minister-designate
and he too is part of the establishment
because he is currently the head of the
intelligence service so it very much
appears that the status quo will remain
and many people even feel that caretaker
Prime Minister Adel Abdel Mukti may
actually remain in place if the
political factions failed to agree on a
replacement there is a growing feeling
now that Idol of Bill Martin may
actually whether this political storm
and remain in power until the next
elections in 2020 to Samara Fulton there
live for us in Baghdad with all those
latest developments thank you Simona